more than 100 protesters have been
injured after a protest near the
Eritrean Embassy in Tel Aviv turned
violent fighting started after
anti-government protesters demonstrated
outside an Eritrean Embassy event the
Israeli police fired stun grenades and
tear gas to stop the violence dozens of
arrests have been made more than 30
Israeli police officers were also
wounded let's cross to Paul Brennan in
the occupied East Jerusalem and Paul
what sparked this violence
well there are tensions existing across
Europe frankly and even in North America
between eritreans who are loyal to the
president of Eritrea and those who
believe that he is a dictator and those
tensions are particularly prevalent here
in Israel where there is around 20 000
eritreans living and the official
statistics don't divide between who are
pro and who are anti-president after
working the events that's the sparked
all of this was an event organized by
the Eritrean Embassy down in Tel Aviv
near the coast
and the people who are against the
president denounced this event as
effectively a festival celebrating
dictatorship they say that they informed
the Israeli police that they were going
to be demonstrating at that event they
urged the Israeli police to get the
event event canceled for fear that
violence might result at that
demonstration in the circumstances the
the police decided to keep the event
going but we now know that as soon as
the demonstrators reached the venue
violence broke out and the police
initially were taken by surprise the
Israeli police saying that they weren't
expecting violence on the level that we
saw we saw rocks being thrown we saw
trees in plant pots being overturned we
saw missiles of various kinds as in
rocks and Sticks and Stones being thrown
backwards and forwards and the police
were essentially in the middle we've had
at least 140 people injured 30 of them
police officers 6 seen people are in
serious condition and they've been 39
arrests so far according to the police
what the police are now saying is that
the event has calm down and they'll
continue patrolling the area but the uh
the the tension between these two two
communities of Eritrean the Eritrean
diaspora if you like who are loyal to
the president and the Exiles who fled
Eritrea because of the president's rules
since 1993 uh the tensions very close to
the surface
okay Paul thanks very much sounds like
quite a major event that
um thanks very much for joining us from
occupied East Jerusalem